Vor 16 millionen jahren soll der urzeit heim megalodon
ausgestorben sein doch es gibt nicht wenige die fest davon überzeugt sind dass eines der größten meerestiere aller zeiten heutzutage
Immer noch in der tiefsee lebt ihr habt euch dieses video bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt deswegen jetzt alle wichtigen facts zum uhrzeit
Wie realistisch ist es wirklich dass er auch heute noch die gewässer unsicher macht also jetzt in science fiction herzlich willkommen
Den link zur whatsapp gibt's wie immer am ende
Des videos der uhrzeit ein mega london gehört mit zu den größten reihen die jemals auf der erde gelebt haben er war wirklich riesig
Rekonstruktionen des kiefers lassen auf eine körperlänge von
17 metern schließen dass es drei mal so groß wie der weiße hai einige seiner zähne waren wohl unglaubliche 17
Zentimeter lang so groß
Also wie eine menschliche etwas größere hand und diese zähne machen es möglich dass sowohl
wasser
Als auch delfine auf seiner speisekarte standen es war der räuber schlechthin ganz oben in der nahrungskette
Und hat wohl in warmen und flachen gewässern seine beute gejagt doch fest steht auch es gibt keinen beweis dafür
Dass der urzeit tatsächlich ausgestorben ist und nicht
zu vergessen die berichte von riesigen kraken sie
Ungeheuern wurden auch jahrzehntelang für seemannsgarn gehalten bis sie entdeckt wurden erst seit einigen jahren ist klar es gibt die
riesenkraken und immer mal wieder tauchen videos und fotos
Im netz auf die ihn zeigen sollen also jetzt den riesenhai wir werfen jetzt mal
einen blick auf die fakten die einst zeugen berichten von riesigen hallen immer mal wieder tauchen fotos
Gigantischer haie auf große diskussion gab es auch
Um ein bild das in dem film megalodon der monster einlebt gezeigt wurde
einrücken und schwanzflosse neben einem u-boot doch das war kein dokumentarfilm sondern
eine mockumentary also keine echte dokumentation ein hinweis darauf gab es lediglich
im abspann die wissenschaftler
Im film waren schauspieler und der hai in gewisser weise wohl auch denn wenn die
Proportionen korrekt gewesen wären hätte es sich um einen 20 meter langen
Gehandelt also ein fünftel größer als sehr gut ein zudem gibt es auch immer wieder, mal
zeichnungen von leuten die den uhrzeit gesehen haben wollen doch klar ist
skizzen von augenzeugen sind keineswegs
wissenschaftlich und ein beleg für seine existenz
Viel wahrscheinlicher ist es dass bei der identifikation ein fehler passiert ist auch riesenhaie oder viel zu groß
da gestellte weiße haie könnten stattdessen
gesichtet worden sein die zwei
andere fischarten leben auch noch obwohl man sieht für ausgestorben geht sprich die entdeckung des riesen maul heiß und der quastenflosser
Dafür dass auch der megalodon noch existiert auch bei diesen beiden fischarten ging man davon aus dass sie lange
ausgestorben sein seit knapp
65 millionen jahren und ja auch der riesenhai ist groß fünf meter etwa und blieb lange von uns
unentdeckt ein beweis ist aber dass noch lange nicht denn auch der riesen maul
Hat es uns wirklich schwer gemacht sein hobby ist es
verstecken zu spielen und das in großen tiefen drittens der urzeit drei
versteckt sich vor uns apropos verstecken ist es nicht sehr wahrscheinlich dass sich der urzeit
vor uns in extremen tiefen versteckt eher
unwahrscheinlich denn seine fossilien zeigen dass er wie gesagt wohl eher in warmen und flachen gewässern wie
beispielsweise
küstengebieten gelebt hat zudem gibt es heutzutage hinweise darauf dass durch seine umsiedlung in kältere gewässer
Wohl mit ein grund dafür sein könnte dass
er ausgestorben das konkret gehen wissenschaftliche studien in renommierten fachzeitschriften
Davon aus dass der urzeitriesen heiligen starker konkurrenz und beute mangel aus stadt und ja es
Stimmt wir haben bisher wirklich nur kleine teile unserer ozeane gesehen und der kunde doch fest steht auch dass die meisten
Lebewesen in den ersten paar hundert metern leben dort wo auch sonnenlicht
hinkommt und das leben in extremen diesen das ist schon sehr speziell und große tiere sind dort bis auf
Ausnahmen ganz weit unten eher selten vielleicht hat er sich ja auch
Zu einem kleineren hay entwickelt der auf die tiefe spezialisiert ist ja und viertens der urzeit
hinterlässt spuren bei einem australischen
forschungsprojekt wurde staunen liches entdeckt eigentlich wollten die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler analysieren wie der weiße hai beute macht doch dann
passierte die überraschung der weiße hai wurde
gefressen der sender von shark alpha zeigte plötzlich eine rasante geschwindigkeit an der weisheit tauchte in eine tiefe von
580 metern der sender verzeichnete zudem einen temperaturanstieg von abt grad celsius auf
26 grad celsius und das innerhalb von sekunden und das ist tatsächlich
eine temperatur wie sie in
Dieser extrem tiefen uhr im magen eines tieres herrschen kann acht tage lang passierte nichts der sender zeichnete
konstant diese temperatur auf und bewegte sich irgendwo zwischen 100 metern und der wasser andersrum der 100 metern und der wasseroberfläche
Dann wurde er wohl?
losgelassen und an den strand gespült das
Forschungsteam weiß bis heute nicht wer mag alpha so in die tiefe gezogen hat war es ein megalodon
Ausschließen können wir es nicht doch es gibt auch andere
Erklärungsansätze ein artgenosse der aufgrund eines genetischen defekt so groß geraten war beispielsweise und das ist tatsächlich die
Einzige winzige spur ansonsten gibt es keine anderen entdeckung
beispielsweise bissspuren und narben von kämpfern walen und delfinen geschweige denn eine aufnahme von
Dementieren wenn ihr als erste erfahren wollt wenn diese tatsächlich aufgespürt wird dann meldet euch hierbei
Whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video auch, zu allen anderen themen
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos stellen
Der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit
Genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
Dafür draufklicken mehr monsterwellen auf ozean gefahr auf dem meer ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran